this is a cue for us to begin with the
tribute to an actor who had one of the
most memorable and hilarious guest roles
on seinfeld the library cop tracking
down an overdue book watch this
i saw you on tv once i remembered your
name from my list i looked it up sure
enough it checked out you think because
you're a celebrity that somehow the law
doesn't apply to you that you're above
the law certainly not well let me tell
you something funny
[Laughter]
we're all laughing uh but because we are
memorializing phillip bakerhall of
course as lieutenant joe bookman of the
new york public library hall died on
sunday he was 90 years old the longtime
character actor appeared in dozens of
films and tv shows including boogie
nights magnolia and family ties his wife
holly says hall died peacefully
surrounded by family and friends but the
laughter remains as if you gotta go
that's the way to go surrounded by
family and friends and your 90s
something and peacefully i didn't know
the name but i certain when i saw the
face i knew insulin and the voice
so memorable and that scientific
appearance really changed his life
a lot of parts after that amazing actor